hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from the 1959
candidates tournament now in this game
you know it seems like nothing is really
happening but then someone takes a
couple of risks and in the end it pays
off now
Mikkel tall has the white pieces in this
game he's playing the Icelandic
Grandmaster freely Koloff son and I
couldn't find a photo of the two of them
playing so here we can just enjoy this
photo of all the participants of the
1959 candidates now someone asked in the
comments last time I shown this photo
who are all of them you know in order
now I don't think the first two from the
left are actually players because I
can't make out who they are the first
one Canada's have petrosian's knows but
he's I don't know I don't think that's
actually Petrosyan the second person
from the left I don't know who that is
the third one is style fourth is glico
rich then we have Smith Slav then in the
middle we have Powerbank oh and Bobby
Fischer and all the way to the right we
have Friedrich Olufsen and Paul Karras
but if any of you maybe have some better
understanding of this photo do share in
the comments so that being said let's
see this game like I said it all has the
white pieces and the opening is pretty
much the standard rule opens Murphy's
defense so we're not gonna dwell too
long on that so II 4 E 5 9 f3 knight c6
Bishop to b5 Dora Lopez a6 we have more
fees defense Bishop to a 4 9 f6 castles
the Bishop to e7 rook to e1 and b5 so
Bishop to b3 we have castles and c3 and
here d6
we have h3 now Knight to d7
we have d4 and the Knights to b6 9 B to
d2 he captures on d4 seek a person
before and now d5 we have Bishop to see
to enforcing that efore pawn and also
creating some future threats towards the
black King Bishop to e6 and now II five
locking the center Queen 37 we have 9th
to b3
Knight to a4 and now Bishop to g5 and
that this is a
the first moment where were towel plays
a move and all of us on has to really
make a decision now it's stop giving up
the beat upon what's the idea of the
night captures on b2 well if you played
this night capture some be to you
immediately get Bishop captures on h7
now if you don't accept the bishop you
play King h8 them Queen to e2 you won
your pawn back you're threatening the
night if the knight moves back the light
square Bishop simply moves back but
again if you capture it then comes Queen
to be one check and after Bishop to a5
blocking check then simply queen capture
some b2 you win back your pawn and you
kind of messed up blacks King side so
all in all it's perfectly fine for white
so I while playing Bishop to g5 tall
isn't actually blundering upon here we
have night the b4 buy all of Sun and now
Bishop captures on e7 Queen captures
only seven and now Queen to be one
pressuring that h7 pawn and here you
know it's hard to say what's a good move
what's not a good move but Knight
captures and c2 should be an automatic I
mean you definitely want to get rid of
this battery I engage seven but here all
of some decides the first play h6 kind
of stopping the idea of Knight coming to
g5 also now Bishop to h7 isn't much of a
threat and it's probably since Thal kind
of invited all of them to do it probably
that's why all of soon didn't do it so
top plays rook to c1 as this is a
backward C pawn so always always nice to
have your rook and c1 rook a to c8 and
now probably preparing to capture the
bishop and on the next move here tal
played Bishop to h7 check and I'm sure
you'll agree this is a weird-looking
move what's the idea of Bishop to h7 so
came to h8 and here Tull plays Knight to
c5 and here you have again a choice to
make
do you try and trap the bishop with the
g6 or if you don't do this so what do
you do what move would you play here as
black if we decide to go for something
like Knight captures on c5 which is like
the immediate idea after rook captures
on c5 that's a pretty
Sorokin c5 and if you still decide not
to go for the way before the bishop if
you play something like Bishop to d7
because here white is actually
threatening a3 and winning this night so
Bishop to d7 guarding the c6 squared but
now Bishop to a5 and after night comes
to c6 now you can simply capture capture
and play Queen to d3 white is preparing
rook a to c1 doubling rooks on the C
file White has all the activity he wants
here
so after this night the c5 move all of
Sun doesn't really have a good follow up
and he ended indeed plays g6 and while
this is the strongest move also I will
have to quote George Waitzkin here it's
a deadly dare to give a guy like tall so
tall of course as now the thread of skin
captures Bishop top plays Bishop
captures and g6 we have F captured sorry
first Knight captures and c5 getting rid
of that of one more piece as tal is
sacrificing a piece so you want to get
rid of as many pieces on the board as
possible
rook captures and now F captures and on
g6 Queen captures on g6 so tall did grab
two points for the piece and he's
threatening to capture the h6 pawn
unfortunately you cannot defend it eh
six pawn so tal will grab that one as
well the Queen cannot come to defend s
she has to keep an eye on the bishop on
e6 so rook to f7 Queen captures on h6
grabbing a third a third phone for the
piece rook to h7 and now how do you
continue your attack here is white but
that's the thing you don't tau just give
a piece for three points so it's not
really a sacrifice here at all plays
Queen to f6 check and he offers a trade
of Queens all of stone accepts Queen
captures pawn captures and here we have
Knight to d3 if you look at this
position all of so now okay that rook on
h7 is pretty active with the bishop on
e6 is pretty nice the broken c8 isn't
really doing anything and this nitin
before isn't really helping much so here
a knight the d3 was played kicking away
the rook from c5 also attacking the b2
born
now played rook the c6 attacking the ace
exponent and the bishop and this is the
critical moment of the game where where
all of some could have gained the upper
hand on tall but in the end he didn't so
you're playing this position tile just
played rook the c6 you're playing the
black pieces you are free big Olaf son
trying to try to try and find the best
idea here for black so you know I will
give it a couple of seconds as I mean
this is a position you yourself will
probably get a lot of times in your
games so it's you know an interesting
idea so for those of you who found the
move it's not really like you like
solving the position is just crippling
white just a little for his you know
route play so here are all of some
missed Bishop captures on on h3 because
now well for one you you grab the pawn
back and you know and now Dallas still
up two points but the DF pawn is doubled
and without the H pawn this isn't really
such a massive pawn storm and now if you
capture it G captures an h3 you get rook
captures on h3 and now after 95 you're
getting a rook to g8 check King moves
now Knight captures pawn captures rook
to h1 and after King moves you capture
the rook and a1 and even with the too
strong passed pawns the two rooks will
win this game as black of course after
this Bishop captures an h3 white it
doesn't have to capture the Bishop white
will probably play Knight to g5 attack
your rook and the bishop but only then
you play Bishop to d7 attacking White's
rook and after white captures on a6 you
attack the knight Knight moves and now
rook comes to g8 and you've you've
crippled white enough to to play this
game as black but after this rope to c6
move all a stone went for Bishop to d7
immediately so here top laid rook
captures on a6 now all of some brought
is rockin Rock the g8 and we have h4 now
by tau and now you can see the four
points here even with the double death
born this is a much much better
structure and windows pawns start
marching forward it will be a lot more
dangerous than without the h-bomb
here all of them played Knight to f4
threatening that g2 born we have g3 and
now Knight to h3 check King to g2 and
now Bishop to g4 still protecting the
knight on h3 also pressuring the knight
on f3
we have Knight to e5 attacking the
bishop there and now first Knight to f4
check and it's an interesting idea
of course if you capture the knight pawn
captures you get Bishop to c8
you window broken a6 so after this
Knight to f4 we have King to h2 by tau
and now another interesting move by all
of song he plays Bishop to e6 it's again
not not a very powerful move maybe
Bishop to see it was a better idea but
of course the idea is that you can't
capture the night if captured rook
captures on h4 is checkmate
so after this Bishop to e6 tal simply
ignores it plays rook to e1 and now we
have Bishop back to f5 and here you
don't really I mean you could play
something like Bishop to c8 attacking
White's rook on a6 and after the rook
moves you can bring the knight back to
safety for example Knight to d6
but still this the the threat of f7 is
simply too great
so after this rook to e1 move off some
tried Bishop to f5
but now tile immediately of course
pushed f7 and now you can see the
problem this rook can no longer stay on
the G file if it moves anywhere along
the G filed and f8 promotes the Queen so
rook to f8 blocking and now simply G
captures on f4 as now there is no more
checkmate
with row captures on h4 so row captures
on h4 we have King g3 now rook to h3
check King to g2 only move and now came
to g7 we have rook to e3 offering to
exchange rooks but of course rook to h5
now rook to g3 check King moves and
after
rope to g5 attacking the bishop and
offering to trade and other perks here
also resigned the game
because if you move the rook of course
you lose the bishop and if you decide to
move the bishop you lose the road
only thing you can really do is capture
it but then after F captures on g5 now
the pawns have undable there are no more
triple pawns and be a file and now it's
it's just a just a winning position for
white after something like into g7 King
g3 you can see that black doesn't really
have a useful move white can you know if
white doesn't even want to calculate it
and I think you can just push be 3 a4
and create a passport on the queenside
if black tries to activate in any way
for example this rook has nowhere to go
to become active if you try something
like rock to h8 you're immediately
getting rook to f6 attacking the bishop
the bishop moves and now Knight to d7
guarding the f8 Square there is no more
stopping f8 Queen you can block with the
rook but then you're gonna lose the
exchange in the game Bishop captures now
you simply promote and you're up a whole
rook you know there's there's no point
in continuing this so after rook to g5
all often resigned the game and you know
it's a very nice example of just another
game in this tournament where tall kind
of tried something and it worked out for
him in the end but it's a stall always
said you know fortune favors the strong
so even though he didn't play the most
precise moves in the end he was the
stronger player and managed to prevail
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it once again you know we don't
want our vast knowledge of the 1959
candidates tournament to suffer so here
are the final standings as you can see
tile who play in this game won first
place with 20 out of 28 and Olaf's own
won second place with 10 out of 28
points so you know a very nice
tournament for for tile and you know not
so great for all of them but in I mean
it was a pretty strong competition so
yeah like I said I do hope you enjoyed
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon